[Musique]
prolonger le pompon pas allons sur la
peur aux propos soir petit ami ça fait
plaisir de voir nounours higuain n'est
ce pas je peux y aller
patron mais bien sûr nounours moi je
suis à petite échelle ou où l' on joue
on secoue au le poster ou non qu'est ce
qu'un coffre du cher à vendetta borloo
lieu c'est mon échelle elle s'est cassé
ma pauvre petit cheveu mort vient
achètent ou louent aux stocks non vendus
dont ils pensent à 8 ans pauvreté rieur
son pass terrienne nicolardot c'est ma
petite chaîne n'est pas seul il les gaz
qu'est ce que je vais devenir si je n'ai
plus de cheveux pneus
tu pourras peut-être plus des sommes
nous voir au lot mais tu peux pas
remonter nos pays peut te pousse trop
allez viens
assieds toi grosse catastrophe au bond
au bout studio et ça vous fait rire mais
bien moi je vais à réparer mon échelle
d'accord nous et on va t'aider
voilà une grande aiguille et une fille
je préfère renault la fille
et voilà comment tu vas faire tiens
tiens ce bout de chaîne du cola et toi
pas preneur tu tiens l'autre côté et moi
je vais faire un peu au match aller où
vous allez voir ça
la donner
allez-y vous pouvez tirer dessus
attention aux ailes et sa lutte à
réparation nounours mot pauvre petit et
seule semaine et pleure pas et suit les
grosses et la promo choir on va te
refaire une autre déchet silva dit mon
petit pas trop
voilà à trop haut il corde à noeuds je
suis sauvé au revoir les enfants avaient
vite vous coucher un double et des mains
entre à une telle échelle très solide
c'est promis non merci
mes chers petits bonne nuit la nuit
[Musique]
courage nounours ça y est presque
attrape ma main là
[Musique]
merci patron c'est pas facile
la corde à gauche ça fait maigrir
nounours vous croyez moi je préfère
l'upl allons en route
bel athlète
venue des enfants allez vite vous
coucher l'effet de pauvres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]